wouldn't it be great to live in the
world of star wars oh sure you might
have to deal with random incursions on
your home planet by jerks and fancy
helmets you might run afoul of some
rough-and-tumble characters at your
local Cantina or you might be one of
those characters and end up getting your
arm sliced off by an old British dude
with a lightsaber
all kinds of crazy things might happen
in that world but a crazy things happen
in our real world - it'd be mostly a
hoot
unless of course you end up working for
the Empire if you think your boss is
always on your back or intrudes too
heavily upon your privacy just wait
until you hear about the working
conditions of your average Imperial
stormtrooper and in particular what
really goes on inside those helmets
before we get into all of that though we
should get this out of the way not just
anybody can fill out an application
undergo a background check and put on
that iconic white armor all set for the
first day of trying and failing to shoot
rebel soldiers in the early days of the
empire stormtroopers were recruited
exclusively from the ranks of the clones
being produced on the planet Kamino an
operation that was once overseen by the
deadly mercenary Jango Fett this is why
and many of their cinematic appearances
stormtroopers all sound the same or all
the same Heights and are all left-handed
as time went on and the cloning
operation was eventually shuttered the
Empire began to recruit stormtroopers
from its human population but they had
to be rigorously tested for absolute
loyalty they also presumably had to
demonstrate with their blaster rifles
that they couldn't hit the broadside of
a barn once they were deemed compliance
and loyal stormtroopers were totally
trusted to carry out their orders and
faithfully represent the Empire without
supervision or scratch that that's a lie
actually it was kind of the exact
opposite of that stormtroopers were
required to stay in uniform basically at
all times while they were on duty which
isn't fun but also isn't the bad part
while they were putting in the work for
their hard earned credits they were also
being watched and each stormtroopers
helmet was a comm device which broadcast
everything that they said all the time
to the Empire where it was monitored and
recorded it was basically like being the
target of a super high-tech surveillance
program broadcasting from your face and
always listening these guys were getting
EES dropped on by the boss every minute
of
shift this served two main purposes
ensuring they remained productive and
squelching potentially rebellious speech
now to be sure stormtroopers armor and
helmets had some pretty sweet features
as well they were designed to dissipate
energy and the helmets provided filtered
air and an awesome heads-up display
which compensated for their limited
field of vision but apparently did
nothing to help them fire their blasters
more accurately the fact that the
stormtroopers speech was constantly
monitored raises an interesting
certainty there were millions of those
guys and somebody had to be doing all of
the monitoring perhaps this was done by
specially programmed droids but we like
to think that somewhere on some planets
was what basically amounted to the
biggest call center you've ever seen
with cubicles stretching as far as the
eye can see in each cubicle set alloy
but underpaid minion of the Empire
grinding through the daily slog of
poring over the audio records of
whatever stormtrooper they'd been
assigned to in the break room they would
boast to their co-workers about how
loyal and professional their guy was
they'd make excuses for his poor
marksmanship whispering under their
breath that those heads-up displays were
made by some shady manufacturer on the
outer rim and when their guy inevitably
got blasted into oblivion or carved up
by a Jedi Knight they'd be allowed to
take five and solemnly reflect on a
sacrifice while listening to the
Imperial March maybe living in the world
of Star Wars wouldn't be so awesome
after all check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]